hey guys i'm gavin leatherwood and today
i'm with buzzfeed to revisit the past by
making a playlist of my favorite songs
from when i was a teenager
if you want to listen along click the
link in the description
to access my playlist
[Music]
so i graduated high school in 2012 i
grew up in orange county california in
the sleepy little town of yorba linda
and we're kind of bored and found lots
of trouble by like
you know skateboarding in schools when
they were empty
and stuff like that a lot of angst in
those years
i was a very sensitive little boy i like
grew up doing musical theater and i came
back into the world of public school in
seventh grade
which like seventh and eighth grade are
the worst years
puberty's hitting and you're changing
and like this is me and my pops
i had like a middle part haircut like a
roller backpack and a star wars tee and
orange cargo shorts that were like
the zip off kind that i thought were
super cool and i got
bullied a lot for it and i saw like the
skaters and all of them
never took any beef from anyone and i
was like
those guys and so my acting career kind
of started again there and i
like shaved my head and wore like big
baggy shirts and little skinny jeans and
like
i really more pretended to skate i
wasn't that good we like put up little
personas to kind of
act as a defense mechanism so i was like
a
faux skater with a shaved head which
doesn't look good on me because i have a
little peanut head
and i like played sports and then
realized i hated it and traded it for a
guitar at some point
it feels like ages ago it's so weird to
do a deep dive into your past
it's so trippy all right first song on
the playlist
is eyes open by taylor swift this song
was
a set song that me and my buddy played
call of duty to
it was my sister's boyfriend and he
would like skateboard over to our house
and they wouldn't end up hanging out if
i would always steal my sister's
boyfriends
and end up like hanging out with them so
me and him would literally park our
butts on a couch
play call of duty zombies and we would
do it to the sweet sweet tune of eyes
open by taylor swift
the beautiful sounds of that mixed with
the killing of zombies that was
strangely complimentary and keep your
eyes open we were like
glued to tv and with video game
controllers and i'm pretty sure we beat
our high score listening to this tune so
it's definitely
capable of bringing about magical
moments feeling this by blink 182 is
second up on the playlist ladies and
gentlemen
it was one that i knew every single word
to and could sing nonstop
it's really kind of weird how i would
listen to this song which
it's about sex okay it's about sex but i
didn't know that all right i didn't i
was just like
i just liked that
and i'd listen to it before going into
wrestling practice which is the weirdest
time to probably listen to that song
and then go you know wrestle around with
a bunch of sweaty
boys and and do that thing and i still
know every single word to it
turn all the lights down now feeling
this it's a damn good one
pressure by paramore number three
this was just another one of those
general angsty teen songs
and she's still killing it and when you
talk about like that artist factor of
people that like
got the thing like the charming charisma
thing
she's got the thing it had a huge impact
on me as a kid whereas just like
get with your friends in a room and
you're like jumping on the couch in the
bed kind of stuff
and just thrashing around she's she
started a thrashing phase in me
which i didn't even know i had in me
until paramore so thanks haley
number four thrift shop macklemore this
is when i started getting into a phase
of
thinking i was like a lot cooler than i
really was
he got me with the first couple of lines
on this song like
before he even started talking it was
the what what
what what what and macklemore can we go
thrift shopping
something so fun and like uplifting
about it and i'm pretty sure he
inspired loads of people to put on their
grandparents clothing and call it cool
because
that trend has not stopped kudos
macklemore you did it
this is yonkers tyler the creator i was
listening to this when i was like
16. it sort of like redefined rap and
was just this huge
thing and you could like feel the
magnitude of
of what he was doing in in the form of
creativity and expression
the video tripped me out if you haven't
seen it like it's super dark
so brace yourselves there was an element
about him that wasn't trying to be cool
it was like he was very much in his body
and knew who he was and you can see it
like when he raps too
because everything had felt sort of
manicured up to this point his stuff
just felt genuine and raw
and real and like dark it's definitely
inspiring
in in many ways but i won't be emulating
this
that same style i don't think i'm a
softie
he's a hard ass man number six
my name is by eminem i was listening to
this song in my ipod
mini in the back of seventh grade math
class when we got to just do work and
put headphones in this is before they
started realizing that
whatever was happening in these little
things were incredibly distracting in
some way
and i would listen to that on repeat
it's such a
vulgar song and there's like such a
visual storytelling element that eminem
had
that he painted this really
obvious and distinct picture with his
words there's this element of
violence and anger in his stuff that was
sort of perfect for
the seventh eighth grade years of like
trying to figure it all out
and that gripped me it was just like i
had never heard that before and there's
like a little kid yeah yeah yeah
this is your life by switch foot switch
but crushed it for me when i was a kid
it was what i was listening to it might
have been like slightly before teenage
years but it definitely carried on into
teenage years
and they put me in my feelings in such a
way looking out of a bus
window listening to this and crying by
myself you know what i mean like it had
that sort of thing
those were like some of the first lyrics
i started really paying attention to as
a listener
you know this is your life are you who
you want to be this is your life is it
everything you dreamed it would be
and there was something that like crept
into my conscience as a young kid
of of wanting to live up to my own
expectations so you know they made a big
impact on me in some way
it's heartfelt and sweet as hell little
iron man
by mumford and sons it was sort of my
first initial introduction to
what folk music sort of sounded like
where
you know it was mostly acoustic
instruments and like banjos and and
stand-up basses and
and whatnot it inspired me to like pick
up a guitar because i saw these like
cool dudes playing music and
i remember girls being like oh my god
like mumford and sons like they're so
cute and they
i love their songs and i was like
i gotta get a guitar it started
something that
hasn't ended and my love for folk music
has just grown
stronger and stronger out of that
budding seed
this has crashed into me by dave
matthews band i
was a really big romantic as a kid i
think i really
loved the rom-com-esque movies
i just wanted to fall in love i didn't
even know what that means i still don't
know what that means
really music was something that
transported me close enough to feel the
feelings of what love
felt like in whatever my teeny tiny
little child heart could feel at the
time
i remember being in love at like 12
years old i would like listen to that
song and like
and she had no idea um i mean she knew i
was in love with her but she didn't know
i was like
you know doing one of those and the tone
of his voice and the swell and the sound
of the music where
you felt some form of like longing and
love
because of it and that's the magic of
music is like
you may not even be able to
intellectualize it but emotionally it
charges you in some way
juicy by biggie i do not condone
smoking marijuana but we'd sit in the
parked
driveway and lead like in the car
while listening to this song he made us
feel a lot cooler than we were
it turned me on to his story i started
realizing like
how much story was in rap as well biggie
felt like really hope-filled and
inspiring
stick it to the man stick to your dream
do it for you damn it made you feel like
you can come from
nothing and get to something so
thanks biggie alright guys that was my
ultimate playlist for my teenage years i
hope you enjoyed getting a little sneak
peek into my past
let me know what you thought of my
choices in the comments below and
don't forget to go stream at my single
just for tonight
which you can find under the moniker
leatherwood
on spotify apple music and whatever else
the kids are listening to nowadays thank
you a lot
you